did you know that inosuke from Demon
Slayer was actually raised by a demon
when he was still a baby he lived inside
a demon cult led by upper Moon 2 Doma
his mother was a kind woman who was
abused by her husband and one day she
ran away and took her son inosuke with
her during that time in Japan running
away from home was not socially
acceptable and no one wanted to help the
poor single mother whose name was kotoha
the only place that she could find
Refuge was the paradise Faith cult when
she found out that the cult leader dolma
was a demon who secretly ate some of his
followers Koto had tried to escape
together with hinosuke tragically Doma
caught her and ate her but inosuke fell
into a river survived and was found by
wild boars sometime later subscribe to
anime uproar for more oh and